économie environnement énergie au social
les
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer comment
éviter de gaspiller du pain au collège
en 2010 nous avons remarqué que deux
kilos et demi de pain été gaspillés par
jour je vais vous montrer comment éviter
cela
pourquoi tu as pris tout ça fallait en
prendre d'autres auraient pu en
reprendre après non mais c'est bon on va
pas se disputer pour deux tranches de
pain ouais c'est vrai en plus ce n'est
pas sa mère bon ok on vous laisse
je suis rassasié tu avais prévenues il
fallait porter notre déficit qui vous
barrent les éco délégués n'avaient pas
vu la fiche
ah ouais c'est vrai
comme le montre ce drapeau qui flotte à
l'entrée du collège
depuis juin 2009 le collège jean des sme
est labellisé éco école au collège
mendès nous incitons chacun à adopter
des éco gestes pour qu'il y ait plus de
solidarité entre nous pour améliorer
notre cadre de vie et pour respecter
l'environnement
je peux économiser jusqu'à 140 euros sur
mes factures edf
comment j'utilise de préférence et
brasseurs d'air si je mets la
climatisation jeu la règle à 25 degrés
et pas plus bas je referme rapidement la
porte de mon réfrigérateur j'utilise des
ampoules basse consommation je choisis
des appareils ménagers étiqueté à plus
qu'ils sont plus économes je place le
congélateur dans un endroit tempéré
j'opte pour un chauffe eau solaire alors
vous voyez préserver l'environnement
c'est augmenter notre pouvoir d'achat le
conseil général agit
le monde durable
économie environnement énergie au social
d
le développement durable à la réunion
c'est maintenant